>>Dan: Dexter's a Big
Picture High School,
and one of the things Big
Picture High School tries
to do is get the students
out into the real world.
So he's interning with us.
>>Laura: One of the best
things about the Learning
Through Internship Program
is the maturity and growth
that you see very quickly,
even from 15-year-old freshmen.
Having students passionate about what
they're doing, really makes a difference
in the schoolwork, so
we're able to connect it.
>>Courtney: The unique thing
about Nashville Big Picture High
School is our students physically come
to our school three days a week.
And on those days, we
focus very intently
on the core subjects that they need.
On the other two days, which
are Tuesday and Thursday,
students pursue their passions
and they pursue their interests
in the community through an internship.
>>Laura: The Learning Through Internship
process, what we call our LTIs,
are a four-year long process.
>>Laura: So wherever you want to begin.
>>Dexter: We can start with this.
I have like three pictures.
>>Laura: We start freshman year
with the students coming in,
doing things such as
taking interest inventories.
They have to create a resume, they
have to practice phone skills.
They have to role-play interviews.
We make them jump through several
hoops before we allow them to go
on an informational interview.
>>Dexter: As my internship,
I want to do architecture.
I want to become an architect, because
my family influence was by my father,
he used to be an architect a while ago.
And then my mom just kept on pushing
me towards that influence, like,
"If you just focus and you put your
mindset to it, then you can do anything.
>>Dan: So you have to know a little
bit about everything of everybody
that you're employing, because
they're a part of your team.
>>Dan: We do a lot of
different things every day.
And I really want to show them that.
We sketch, we design.
>>Dexter: First we had the men and
women's bathrooms set up right here,
and then the janitor's, kitchen,
mechanical room all one side.
>>Dexter: Mr. Tansey gives me objectives
to achieve, and goals to achieve,
and lets me use RevIt and SketchUp which
are two different programs that we use
to make architecture easy
for us instead of drawing.
>>Dexter: It shows me how to
push myself, and it shows me
that other people are helping
me to achieve my goals.
>>Dan: We're also out in the field.
We're talking to contractors,
we're talking to business
owners, we're talking to clients.
>>Dan: Hey, guys [Good morning]
>>Laura: I get onsite
every two to three weeks.
I'm looking for things that he's
seen and things that he's learned.
And it shows that he's
comfortable where he is and maturing
in his professional skills.
>>Dan: He's really, really grown.
I mean, from Day 1, you know, we
were doing sketches; to Day 2,
we're on the computer; to
Day 3, we're in the field.
Him being able to take all that
in, and then understand how all
that comes together, I think, has
been really his great strength.
>>Joe: Up, good, concentrate
on the ball, good!
>>Andi: I'm learning to be a
professional tennis teacher
and professional tennis player.
I'm the youngest Certified Professional
Tennis Registry Member in the country.
>>Joe: Look up, beautiful!
>>Joe: When Andi first came
to me, she was a person
that didn't really think
too much of herself.
>>Joe: One more, up!
>>Joe: The confidence came as
Andi started to take leadership
to support the other kids in the school.
>>Andi: Good, come forward, good!
>>Sherry: Andi's a better student
because her confidence has grown.
But in the beginning, he
spent a tremendous amount
of time with her reading skills.
>>Andi: I really struggled
in the English mostly.
And so at night, I've just been reading
the passage and going through here.
>>Andi: It goes beyond tennis.
He's like a second father to me.
He's helped me in every
aspect of my life.
School, tennis, just being there for
everything that I've been through.
>>Sheryl: Now we're going to get into
writing the equations for each of these.
>>Andi: I feel like I'm more
responsible as a student.
I get my work in on time.
I know if I have a problem,
I can go talk to my teacher,
and that's something I really struggled
with my freshman and sophomore year.
>>Sheryl: The distance from the foci
to any point that's on that ellipse.
>>Andi: Equal distance.
>>Sheryl: There ya go!
>>Sheryl: Andi is in my
Critical Thinking class,
and she's in my Pre-Calculus class.
She is also my daughter!
The internship, it's made her a
better student, because of the--
having more pride and
confidence in herself.
>>Andi: Go.
>>Sheryl: And her dream is to open a
tennis club for the underprivileged.
>>Andi: What's next for me is that
I'm going to either go to college,
or go play on the pro tour.
>>Courtney: We want them to
be excited about their passion
and tie that to their education.
So they can be successful
lifelong learners.
>>Laura: Every high school should allow
the space and the place for students
to explore their passion, even if
it was just for 20 minutes a day.
Maybe it's 45 minutes a week.
I think that they would
see some huge benefits.
>>Joe: Go, whoo, that's
a great shot, thank you.